الاولى ستكون مع مراستنا من مصر ندى حجازي
وتحديدا عن استخدام تقنيه الفار تخيلوا في
امتحانات الثانويه العامه لضبط الغشاشين
بدنا نشوف ماذا ماذا لديك
صباح الخير يا راويه صباح الخير يا عادل
ازيكم عاملين ايه
هو هو فعلا هيتم استخدام تقنيه الفار في
لجان امتحانات الثانويه العامه طبعا بشكل
اخص لان هي بتكون الاكبر والمطلوب فيها
انضباط اكثر على مستوى الجمهوريه وده لضبط
الغشاشين وكمان تنظيم اللجان هو الخبر لقى
تفاعل كبير جدا على السوشيال ميديا يعني
تقنيه هتكون مهمه جدا وهتنظم ولكن كان فيه
برضه جانب يعني دمه خفيف شويه لانه
التقنيه دي طبعا معروفه اكثر انها بتستخدم
في مباريات كره القدم
فا يعني كان في شويه كوميكس بس هم يعني
اخذين الموضوع بشكل جدي ومنظم جدا وكمان
في
مخالفات كبيره على استخدام الهواتف سواء
حيازتها حتى لو كانت مغلقه ده هيعرض
الطالب للرسوب سنه كامله واعاده السنه دي
وهيكون في استخدام للعصيان الالكترونيه
لتفتيش الطلاب قبل وبعد اللجان طب واللي
واللي بيضبطوه بيغش عن طريق الفار بي يعني
ولا ضربه جزاء ولا ايه ايش بالضبط
بيعملوا له طرد من الامتحان كله طيب
موضوعنا الثاني اذا يا ندى عن القانون
اللي اقروا البرلمان المصري لتنظيم حيازه
الحيوانات والكلاب الخطيره طبعا بعد بعد
الحادثه الاليمة اللي اودت بحياه طبعا جار
احدى المذيعات في القاهره من جراء عضه كلب
شو لديك يا ندى
الخبر ده كان فعلا صادم ومحزن جدا جدا على
الشعب المصري كله لان احنا تابعناه
وتابعنا الحاله المتدهوره كمان للمحاسب ده
قبل وفاته
صادر اكثر من مشروع قانون ولكن اقر
البرلمان بصدور مشروع قانون او قانون يعني
بينظم حيازه الكلاب والحيوانات الخطره
وبيمنع عموما حيازتها الا للهيئات العامه
او الوزارات او
المراكز البحثيه اللي بتقتضي التعامل مع
الحيوانات دي اول سيرك او حدائق الحيوان
اللي لازم يكون فيها الحيوانات الخطره
ولكن مش للعامه لان اغلبها اصلا مش يعني
مش مصره حتى بترخيصه والقانون كمان بيشترط
ان حتى ال يعني اللي مسموح للترخيصها لازم
يخطر السلطات لو كان ليها يعني لو اتعدت
باي مرض او حتى لو كان فيه اشتباه لو
تكسرت علشان يتم اا اصدار تراخيص ميلاد
واهم حاجه هي العقوبات اللي هتطبق علشان
برضو الواقعه دي ما تتكررش تاني فاي اي حد
هيكون معاه حيوان خاطر وهيعتدي على غيره
لو الاعتداء ده افضل الى موت
هيتسجن لمده عشر سنوات ندى ان شاء الله
يعني دايما
تكوني معنا شكرا جزيلا لمراسله صباح
العربيه ندى حجازي لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات